this is your round nine recap of the  2014 us chess championships well the  leaderboard was shaken up when  Grandmaster Sam shanklin defeated the  leader of erosion a cobian leaving the  door open for Alex Linderman who  defeated Daniel narrowed its key and  felt thrilled after the game before this  term and I haven't been in Grand Master  in the long game in 16 straight games  but here are 15 games so it's a pleasant  surprise and in the women's  championships it was a battle of great  rivals Grandmaster Irina Krush against  anisette on ski these two ladies have  won the last eight Championships  combined but today it was arena who  proved victorious obviously the goal is  to win and I feel amazing yeah I'm so  happy you know because I did what I  needed to do today join us for the final  exciting rounds of the 2014 us Chess  Championships here in st. Louis at one  p.m. Central at us chess champ calm